when you're stuck the feeling is part of  it's just so frustrating  even if you're moving at a small at a  slow pace  but you're moving in the right direction  it's satisfying  so i always say if you are stuck  somewhere don't worry you're not a tree  your feet not roots you know nothing  against roots and trees  but roots trees with roots cannot move  we as human beings were feet literally  and figuratively as well  can move on in life so in this analogy  of the car i talk about  the car having four wheels the first  wheel  being our personal life the second wheel  being  our relationships the third wheel being  our professional life  and the fourth wheel being a social  contribution  but the steering wheel is our  spirituality